we're going to start off with this story
about the louisville police major
calling black lives matter and antifa
supporters punks oof
so uh let's just i'll just pull the
story right here check it out daily mail
reports louisville police major calls
black lives matter and antifa supporters
punks
who will always be living in their
parents basement and washing
our cars in message to division she
commands
that's a little bold that's washing
washing our cars what does that mean
well that's kind of what they're saying
though isn't it like we don't have any
future because the system is rigged
against us
i i mean it sounds like they're saying
rabble rabble rap
exactly like you know bankers no i was i
was talking to a friend earlier
and and i asked i asked her i was like
do you know because she was talking
about black lives matter and stuff and i
was like do you know how many unarmed
black men were shot and killed last year
by the police
it's like oh i don't know but you can
google it i'm like no i know the number
because i
i have googled it i looked it up and
well i don't know but it's a lot i'm
like it's 13.
i thought it was eight okay so yeah so
uh the wall street journal's number was
nine
but i'm using black lives matter's
number i'm using the washington post's
uh activist number 13. that doesn't mean
uh all innocent people potentially
killed it's unarmed black men who are
shot so it doesn't include women
uh it's 13 and there's 375 million
estimated police interactions
it doesn't sound like hunting or
anything like that yeah and i think
there was a breakdown done
maybe it was either by matt walsh or
michael knowles i apologize for
forgetting who it was but
they actually looked through the cases
of unarmed black men being killed by the
police and some of them
i remember one in particular like an old
woman was being
attacked and so unarmed is tricky
because
people can be armed and the shooting is
unjustified and someone can be unarmed
and the shooting is justified exactly
it's not as helpful a term as people
think it is
but that's it's just a language they use
because
it makes it seem justified exactly like
briana taylor was unarmed
they deemed her killing justified now
i'm seeing all the activists and
everybody's rising up and
and this is the the police officer we're
seeing who's calling them you know
basement
punks we're gonna wash our cars is
louisville and that's where it's all
going down
but the justify doesn't mean i think a
lot of people understand this too
justify doesn't mean
warranted it doesn't mean good yeah it
means the police were it were
were cleared in that circumstance to
fire that gun yep
and so that's what happened you know
with with briana taylor of course
all we get from the left is and i'm not
trying to blanket every single person
but yeah too many of them
propaganda she was sleeping in her bed
they fired fired blindly through the
door breaking the door and it's like
none of that happened man none of that
happened
now as for this this uh this lady we
have major bridget
halahan who commands the louisville
metro police fifth division
allegedly sent the message i i think
this is funny
because should we care that she's
insulting them this way
and you're saying you're shaking your
head i don't think it should bother us
all that much i mean they are burning
down our cities i think a couple of mean
words are probably in order at this
point
the first thing i thought about was the
basket of deplorables hillary clinton
comment yeah
yeah well that's incited a bunch of
people and they're
and so i think i i i'm the kind of
person who's like oh who cares he called
them names right
but they're definitely music the left is
going to use this they're going to be
like see what the police are saying and
they killed this person now they're
mocking us on top oh yeah of the murder
of a woman sleeping in her own bed
how long before not true by the way but
yeah how long before they start saying
punk is a dog whistle for something much
more nefarious
oh for sure for sure yeah let me read
this quote she said
these antifa and blm people especially
the ones who just jumped on the
bandwagon yesterday
because they became woke insert eye roll
here
do not deserve a second glance or
thought from us
our little pinky toenails have more
character morals and ethics
than these punks have in their entire
body do not stoop
stop to their level on this stupid i
think she meant do not respond to them
if we do we only validate what they did
don't make them important
because they are not they will be the
ones washing our cars
cashing us out at the walmart or living
in their parents basement playing cod
for their entire life yikes that's all
right that's the that's a little bit
inflammatory
seriously so i feel like she could have
stopped where she was saying do not
stoop to their level because i'm
assuming that and then she did
it to be fair she did not torch a sports
bar
right right right right right she really
stooped to their level but telling the
cops don't go around burning down the
city that's like a really
like the bars on the floor it's like
okay and i'm
gonna walk right over that sure i i'm
interrupted lydia though i'd like to
hear you man interrupted
so i'm just gonna say i feel like that
was really kind of the the
gist of what she was saying but she kind
of cased it in some really snarky
sass i'm like bro that wasn't
professional i mean sis
she's a lady look at us me and lydia are
being so pc tonight
for sure for sure like why is she
ragging on call of duty yeah also yeah
what's wrong with
with call of duty is call of duty played
by like primarily leftists
i don't know i don't know that i don't
think that would be that it's halo you
know
it's probably isn't basement dweller
typically like
the left wing insults the right as
basement dwellers that's everywhere i
find like neckbeard and basement dweller
are just what you call anyone who has
upset you on the internet
yeah sjw women are like lady neckbeards
oh they call them legbeards
like beards i get to hear that one but
you never heard that it's like if
someone disagrees with me they're not
attractive
i can guarantee that's sort of the
thinking that's funny yeah yeah yeah
it's like
is that it it really does make sense
it's as far as they can take it
you insulted me and hurt my feelings and
you're ugly mm-hmm yeah
well that's and that's well it's kind of
what she didn't call him ugly per se
but this is a police officer yeah this
is a major
a major telling telling her command name
calling
yeah insane that that woman is totally
unprofessional and is gonna
do way more damage than she well i mean
the fact that it was released that it
was leaked i guess
oh that was leaked yeah she didn't say
it publicly oh my god she was
she was like sending a message to her
like her co-workers oh well i get that's
ridiculous
i mean a little bit because you don't
want to give them attention you want to
not focus the media on them and just
shut them up and shut them down dude i
hate when this happens i hate all right
it's one thing if they said something
ridiculous and over the top and
inflammatory that was intended to be
inflammatory and was said to the public
but i hate when a private statement
becomes a story
like this when it becomes national news
all right well why isn't if this is so
inflammatory then why isn't the story
about how unbelievably irresponsible it
was for whoever leaked this to leak it
yeah who leaked it it doesn't say does
it um maybe
an anonymous source yes it's an
anonymous source
what do they say uh she oh the daily
mail says this
major bridgette halahan comma who is
white
oh my goodness this changes everything
that's relevant
this is i was okay with her comments at
first but now i'm out did
did you hear what uh maj had to say the
other day to ray from uh black guns
matter
he said that he saw a bunch of white
anti-fun he yelled and i'm like where
are the black people at
no like it's it's it doesn't i i don't
care what
her what her race is these antique
people are mostly white people
going around doing this it's funny yeah
i didn't get to catch the the podcast
you did with maj but
you guys accidentally put my twitter
handle in there so i was getting a bunch
of tweets
for him as the show was going and
they're like at sheamus like they tagged
some college professor look at sheamus
coughlin says you're scared to debate
him
he's like what have i gotten myself into
and you should
i have no idea what we're arguing about
i'll just argue with anybody for any
reason that's
great though so uh it was written by her
so the career journal published the
statement
and uh they don't really i don't think
they say where it came from
uh just and i don't think it's actually
as bad as the daily mail makes out to be
here's another quote from from the from
the email there is currently no recourse
we have for incidents involving doxing
of officers or their families
what we can do is speak up against them
and put the truth out there
through the pio office and the lmpdfb
page
we will come back at them on their own
page to let them and everyone else know
they are lying
we will print the facts i will see to it
we have already taken care of one
incident i hope we never have to do it
again
just know i got your back she was
messaging her
her like her staff because they were
getting doxed by antifa and far leftists
yeah and this was her message
and then she goes on to say you know
what what do you say i am disappointed
oh so this is a metro councilman who's
now dragging her over this oh my god so
this
this is what the media does because they
want to take something salacious and do
whatever they can to make the police
look bad
so if you could you imagine like having
a private conversation with somebody
at work and being like man jerry down in
accounting what a dick
and then someone hears you when they run
and they tell somebody yes yeah exactly
if you're the boss though and you're
trash talking people
that's bad for morale yeah but you're
trash talking to people
who are doxing your subordinates it's
true but i don't think it's the best way
to
boost morale for the team i mean
honestly i think it's
it's a it's a low blow and and somebody
might have saw that
and been like you know this girl's way
out of line here are you saying she
othered them
if she's gonna say that about them she's
probably gonna say that about me no i
don't i don't know
i don't know if the people at work are
like all that concerned that i don't
think the other cops are like oh no
she's gonna
insult me when she's in something
against someone else you can bet that
they're going to do it against you when
you're not around
no no this is tribalism this is the
police saying
she's saying i got your back these
people are bad
what's happening is the media is using
it to say see the cops hate you
the cops think you're losers the cops
the cops think you're gonna wash their
cars
it's like blowing it out of proportion
that's just one girl's opinion now it's
making it seem like it's a police
the police manager says all black lives
matter are punks and basement dwellers
and you know as if she had a public
statement where she wrote asterisk
insert eye roll here asterick instead of
just posting it online
yeah it's ridiculous i'm pretty sure she
did say that yeah that's what you
mentioned right right right it says
parentheses yeah i was like written
statement because when when you were
first discussing it i thought that this
was something she had said publicly
publicly or actually stated out loud but
yeah this is clearly something she wrote
down and
now you've mentioned it was in a private
chat so this is uh
not the story that i thought it was at
first but this is why we have to read
past headlines but many people will not
read past the headline which is a
serious problem this does seem a little
heavy-handed and unprofessional
of her but i also understand what she's
trying to do she's kind of trying to
team build for them she's trying to hype
them up before their big huge um
you know they're tangling with blm and
antifa exactly
yeah they're about to go out and they're
about to get bricks thrown at their
faces
but maybe she shouldn't be riling him up
that way or no no you know what honestly
i think i get what she's trying to do
you got to satisfy that emotion she's
trying to make sure they don't act a
fool these cops don't go out and do dumb
you know dumb things so she's giving
them that emotional satisfaction saying
i get it they're really dumb they're
losers don't stoop to their level
because she doesn't want the cop to go
out there and crack a skull that's
interesting
yeah i i kind of get where you're coming
from if if she wanted them to go out and
do violence against these
these protesters or rioters really what
she would be saying
is they're going to take over this
country and then they're going to be in
charge of you and you're going to be
washing their car
that's the kind of rhetoric you would
expect from a person who wants you to
become angry with the other side but
she's basically boiling them down
to a non-threat yeah i see it like if
this was d
and she was using her charisma she's
instead of choosing persuasion she chose
intimidation
and they're both charisma abilities
that'll work i guess right i mean she's
just trying to get them hyped up a
little bit but not too hyped up she's
trying to show that they're all on the
same team
yeah i don't know well well and this is
also one of those things too where
if somebody hurts somebody that you love
or care about who you're supposed to be
protecting one of the first places you
go is
that person's a loser you shouldn't care
what they think you shouldn't care about
what they do
and these people these people were
doxing police officers for subordinates
so it makes sense for her to be like
look don't worry about them
they're not a threat we're going to keep
them under control but rather
rather than be like that kid's a loser
like it was your mom talking to a kid
that's crying got bullied at school that
kid's a loser anyway or she could be
like that kid
is comes from a troubled family don't
take it personally there's two ways to
explain their behavior one is
intimidative one is
persuasive she should have said to them
we here at the lmpd are better than
antifa
and we know it exactly we're better
people
yeah look at how great we are smile yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go
live don't forget to subscribe hit the
like button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time